[Music]
this
is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host dr john baloney ramsay
personality best-selling author and host
of the dr john deloney show
is my co-host today uh he has a couple
of uh
phd's he's the smartest guy in the
building and if you don't believe me ask
him
and uh also also the most humble i agree
i agree continue
continue so uh but anyway the uh uh yeah
you need to listen to his show it's all
about mental health and boundaries and
relationships and uh you weren't
scheduled to be
involved in the show yesterday but you
got involved behind the scenes a little
bit
yeah for those of you that were not
around yesterday for whatever reason
i don't usually tell you what yesterday
is but all that but this is
the time we're going to stop and do that
um we had a young lady call in
with rachel and i on the air that um
became apparent during the call that she
was
a victim of domestic violence which i
don't even like saying that
that way because it sounds so antiseptic
she was a victim of her boyfriend
beating the crap
out of her is a better way of saying the
truth
and uh we determined that and then
while we were on the call we determined
he was in the room that he had walked in
and was not happy and so um
uh it went from a financial question to
a
question of her safety and her child's
safety and so forth on the air
live that's pretty wicked weird and wild
but
um walk her through that a little bit
and um
john just happened to walk by the studio
and stepped in and i put her on hold and
he does a lot has done a lot of
trauma and uh crisis uh
intervention type counseling over the
years and so
um trained in that but also experienced
in that so we got
you got on the phone with her and um we
were able to get the uh
the police over there very quickly and
uh the young man is sitting where he
should be now in a cage
um which is where people like that
belong
um and so i think they call that a jail
but i called it a cage
um very simple either one is very either
one's fine with me but they're both
similar situation here this is where
this little guy needs to be
and uh so that was pretty wild
discussion you were having in there off
air
yeah i i noticed at one point i didn't
know who would who was in there
you know you kind of zone out and lock
try to lock
in in face to face you lock eyes but in
those situations you lock hearts with
somebody
and then i noticed you'd come in there
after a while but yeah it was
intense mainly because it was live it
was happening live
and she was not it wasn't
philosophically unsafe she was unsafe
now and somebody else had her kid
and then you've got a mom who needs to
protect herself but i'm not going to
leave my baby unprotected and now you've
got a messy situation
and whenever i show up to something like
that i'm always looking at escalation
trends is this thing slowing down are
people separating and they just yelling
at each other or is it moving up and
this one moved up
real rapidly and um luckily that police
department there was super responsive
and they showed up and i'm grateful to
them and
at the end of the day man we're talking
to a really brave
brave young woman brave new mom and
she's got a hard row ahead of her but
yeah things got pretty dicey there for a
minute
yeah and that's not that's not us
hollywoodizing this thing no it got
pretty nice it was it was very real yeah
and uh
he's a violent dude and uh so
the uh yeah of course
so the end of the story is she's safe
for her families around her
and of course we're gonna uh we've
plugged her in with financial counseling
she does have some
crisis financial situation as well and
she's got some resources there some
domestic violence really was not even on
the table for discussion yesterday
so but our our team is rallying around
her we're plugging her in with
counselors not
of course no charge and we're just going
to walk with her and make sure she gets
gets her life uh changed in a different
direction because it sure was going down
the toilet pretty fast there
and we did we connected her some um
domestic violence resources there in
tampa too so that
she can have a local community that can
be hands-on there yeah and
yeah so so she's safe and good for those
of you that were listening a lot of you
been
you know emailing us and worried and so
forth and uh so we thought we would give
you guys
a bit of an update and you know it's odd
you and i were talking i think it was
last week on the air
about this correlation between um
extreme control over money issues and
domestic violence yeah
that there's a correlation between that
because there's this where uh where a
husband or a boyfriend it will not let
you
pick the cereal at the grocery store you
can't go grocery shopping by yourself
you can't
buy detergent you can't do anything
without his approval on every little
nuanced thing where there's that level
of weird
toxic control over a lady
a woman uh with the money
it's it's a high statistical indicator
that he's probably hitting her
it's just about power right and i'll
take that power over i can get it
yeah it's about power and control and
boy you know that was going on yesterday
and you could smell it in the air so i
put her on the air
air it was um it didn't take a genius to
figure out what was to you know to
figure out what i was dealing with what
we're going into there but
you know i think the the thing that um
you can't get away from on the positive
side
or the negative side of toxic toxic
behaviors
is that um our behaviors is that
personal finance is 80
behavior it's only 20 head knowledge so
the chances of you being in a
relationship that are that dysfunctional
and being wealthy
yeah uh becoming wealthy in a
dysfunctional setting is just
almost impossible right because these
things don't live
in one nice little compartment over here
uh
and then not bleed over or not not
bad bad metaphor but don't don't reach
over into the other areas of your life
absolutely
i mean you can't be a punching bag in
one area of your life and then suddenly
be prosperous and healthy and
winning at your career and winning at
your wealth building that kind of they
just don't it's not
we can't compartmentalize that tight
right and one of the challenge with
relational abuse of any kind is
you accept that as a given you accept
that as
well some days are good days
occasionally he'll come in crying saying
he's sorry
and it's going to be okay and so you
start trying to solve that inner chaos
at the margins you
start trying to think of well maybe i
can get a better interest rate or maybe
i should trade my car in or it's
probably my job
and you're and you distance yourself
from this core
nuclear reactor issue that is hey you're
not safe
your baby's not safe and this thing just
escalates this way right so
um to anyone the decisions you make on
the money on the fringes to avoid the
nuclear reactor at the center
are never good decisions they're not
because you're making them out of chaos
right well and you're making them
uh to uh in order to mask
that's right and in order instead of
dealing with with the core issues
and so you know larry brickett used to
say dead is not the problem it's the
symptom
there you go and so it's a symptom of a
behavior
well i heard you say something yesterday
through the window that i think's worth
reiterating
you listened to her and you said hey hon
you are
worth being safe you're worth more than
this
and so anybody listening is in any sort
of
abusive situation exhale and drop your
shoulders for a second
and look up in the rearview mirror if
you're driving and look in the mirror at
your house
you're worth being safe
[Applause]
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments
at unbelievable prices and they make it
simple to shop
blinds shades and interior shutters with
easy online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
ellen is in new jersey hi ellen welcome
to the ramsay show
hi how are you today better than i
deserve what's up
um i was just curious me and my husband
we're trying to figure out what to do
about our money because
he's working at a sales shop and he's
not eating as much as we were hoping to
be
your phone your phone sucks can you
speak directly into it we're having
trouble understanding you
uh sure um hang on let me see if you're
leaving my fans too loud hold on
okay is that better yes ma'am thank you
i'm sorry start again so
maybe we can understand you now yeah um
my husband is a sales uh insurance
salesman
and we're projected to make a certain
amount of money but because of uh issues
with his job and things we're not making
enough
um and he has a bad history of like work
history
so we've been trying to repair it by
keeping a job for certain lengths of
time
but we're not really making enough money
to make ends meet so i'm not sure what
we should do
so he's on straight commission and y'all
are starving to death
well he has a little bit uh he's like
two thousand dollars a month
of uh almost two thousand dollars a
month of um
yes but he's obviously not a good
insurance salesman
no unfortunately okay so he does need
another job i don't care what his work
history is
yeah when you say he has a bad work
history you're trying to repair what
does that mean
it means he's not stayed on the job very
long yeah he had a history of not
staying on jobs very long
last few years he's been working on
fixing that why um
are you interesting with his family his
family needed a lot of help
he's kind of off of work a lot and he'd
get fired for those reasons
but um he'd get fired because his family
needed a lot of help you mean because he
didn't go to work
yeah okay when did that stop
that stopped um actually after he
started beating me
i started pushing him to work harder and
he did start working a lot harder
how long ago since then um that's
about 2000 and i'd say about 2018 it
really started improving
okay so he's held a job since 2018
fairly steadily
yeah he's helped different jobs but he's
not like been fired from any of them and
he's gonna steady
being working all the time so that he
has been doing
okay here's the deal he's got to go get
another job he's got to get two or three
of them
and he's not going to make a lot of
money at the hourly wage but he needs to
start making some money
that's where you're at and i know you
all have a dream right now of
hey we're going to make this this is
going to be the job that bails him out
of all the other bad jobs
that's not where you're at right now
y'all got to eat you're an emergency
so he's got to go to lowe's and he's
gotta go drive uber at night and he's
gotta get up and
i don't think they have paper routes
anymore he's gotta find a morning job
too and he's gonna be working three days
three jobs
six days a week seven days a week and
he's just got to get cracking
so um ellen you sound like you're taking
care of a little boy to me
that's exactly right
like he doesn't want to work much like
he's lazy and you're covering for him in
this call
that was the case originally and it's
not anymore i'm actually a stay-at-home
mom
but he's been doing most of the actual
working
i know but he's not he's not working
it's not it's not working
yeah that makes sense yeah like the
reason he sucks as an insurance salesman
is because he doesn't do it
hey he's not making sales
yeah yeah okay so what
what you need to do are you guys in a
good church
actually just joined a better church
wonderful your
church was too far away but now we're
the good ones wonderful okay i want you
to i want him to plug in with some guys
that are a little bit older than him and
start to develop some relationships with
some guys who
have a high quality work ethic
and who have big goals for their lives
and let him start hanging around with
those guys
because i think no one has ever taught
him how to do those things right he's
got some family challenges i get that
um well i think his family that didn't
allow him to work much
so he had to stop and help them they
don't work much that's what i'm saying
any picture of what that even looks like
it's like you know yeah
but i also know guys like this that it's
always a scheme it's the next thing
yeah and well you look for when you're
desperate you look for stupid ideas
there you go
you just need to work real hard for a
long time yeah and don't don't don't
jump on
pipe dreams just go get something where
you can hustle and grind and grind out
some money
yeah and just be steady and be the
tortoise and somebody will be there
ahead of you and you'll get hey i need
you to take this shift we're going to
make your assistant maybe that's how
if you just show up work and work while
you're at work and smile where you're at
work and work while you're at work and
smile while you're at work and you show
up all the time and you do that
all of a sudden magic stuff starts
happening it just does i mean it's just
incredible what ends up happening
because here's the thing
most people don't show up and work at
work or they show up at work and they're
jerks to be around yeah that's the magic
yeah do your job and don't be an idiot
ta-dah make a million dollars that's
like the slogan
i'm gonna write that book do your job
and don't be an idiot how about that
it's like
but i mean that's that's all it's kind
of it's like you know if you just
show up and care fun to be around and
care
all day long and smile while you're
there dad come
man you're just like you're just like in
the top percent right there
before you did anything else you don't
even have to be that good at how did the
bar
for life get so low
just show up to the job that you just
show up
it's not just him we're talking about
everybody now
yes okay so just just yeah be at work
while you're at work work real hard
it's a formula and don't be diddy get
off of facebook you're supposed to be
working
you're supposed to be working and don't
be watching youtube catch
videos everything's supposed to be
working to every guy work while you're
at work who has had a past
where they've struggled and now you're
in it and you've got
a incredible woman like this by your
side and this is going to be the job and
you get in and you're trying to sell
you're trying to sell
and it's not working be honest
be open about it and transition to
something else don't think you're saving
anybody by drowning your whole
family and that's how people end up you
know two years later and sixty thousand
dollars in secret credit card debt
nonsense like that
scott's in dallas texas hey scott how
are you
i'm doing all right how are you guys
better than we deserve how can we help
okay i got a question for you
i am 47 years old and
my fiancee is 39 years old
we are getting married for the second
time
uh each of our second marriages next
month
uh we've been together for about six
years she's a
super great woman and i'm very confident
that this one's gonna work for me
but we're at two ends of the spectrum
when it comes to our finances she
is a 10-year professional she's a
an audiologist and she has about 160 000
in debt most of its student loans
and i have approximate net worth
of 1.9 million
um debt free except for my house so
my question is how do we attack it
attack her debt attack
attack our debt that's not our debt
until you're married
you're married you write a check and you
pay off your debt
i don't have that much cash why you have
a 1.6 million dollars 1.9 million
dollars you don't have 160 grand
what's it in
i have uh four paid off rental
properties
and i have about 375 000
of equity in my own home and i've got
about a half a million dollars in
retirement
and i am down to
60 grand in cash um
and that's why i feel comfortable
because i'm a small business owner you
know i
i got 30 grand in my business and 30
grand in my
emergency i'd sell a rental property
still around property may be debt free
after you're married i'm not walking
around 160 000
in student loan debt and rental
properties on the books
comes with a package brother yeah this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just thirty dollars a month get
unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month
by switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five heath and morgan are with
us in columbus ohio
says on my screen you guys are debt free
congratulations
thank you awesomeness how much have you
paid off
127 000 in two years and 19 days
good for you wow good job well done and
your range of income during that two
years
um right around 108 000 to like 123
000. cool what do y'all do for a living
i'm a project manager at a public
utility
and your your phone cut out you're a
what
more heather i'm sorry morgan i'm a
teacher you're a teacher
great okay wonderful so uh what kind of
debt was your 127 000
um it was like 96 000 in student loans
like 25 000 in cars
and around 6 000 or so in credit cards
so how long y'all been married about
five years yes yeah because that's about
this level of stupid stuff you're doing
yeah
yeah you have about five years worth of
stupid
y'all were normal huh what happened what
woke you up two years ago
so i was at work one day and a co-worker
dropped your name
on my way home i listened to the podcast
and a couple did
their debt free stream with almost the
exact same income
and the exact same amount of debt oh
there it is oh
man and now you're doing that to someone
yeah
yeah i learned how possible it could be
and i
if i recall correctly i think they were
right around the two-year mark as well
so
i came home told morgan about this plan
and she was on board from day one wow
just like that
yeah a podcast on the drive home after a
quick mention
and that's right boom here you go you
guys you guys are easy to convince
[Laughter]
[Music]
and so morgan he comes home and says hey
i've got this wild idea and you said
high five let's do it yeah because the
student loan debt was mine
okay and it was and there was no fun
going on with all this stuff right it
wasn't joyous
oh no no there was some dramatic moments
i'm sure
yeah morgan i know the answer to this
question but i just want you to tell
america
so put us in the teacher lounge at
whatever school you're teaching
and as teachers sit around the table and
talk as they do
you've got 96 000 in student loans for a
teacher's certificate
and i know you're not the only one what
is the debt burden like on these
teachers
uh it's quite extensive a lot of
teachers a lot of teachers have student
loan debt
and uh a lot of them only have
bachelor's degrees you know i was
i ended up with a master's degree so
that increased that loan obviously but
yeah i would say probably 80 percent of
the teachers
that i know have student loan debt well
congratulations on working hard getting
out
so good proud of you guys you're just
amazing what you've done
so when one of them asks you how did you
do it what do you tell them the key to
getting out of debt is
so one we we were both on board and both
we held each other accountable we were
willing to make the big sacrifices like
downgrading in our vehicle choice and
working together and then also having a
support group
we had a couple friends that really
helped us through the journey and
did the journey with us on their own
accord oh cool
okay so you had some cheerleaders and
they were also working it
absolutely our friends trey and courtney
were our biggest cheerleaders by far
very cool good so you got all the
information you needed off the podcast
or did you do something further
um we took financial peace university
after the podcast i
i said well what what else is there
right we need you know i'm a teacher so
i need like rules and expectations
and he was like well there's a book the
total money makeover so we both read
that and then after that and listening
to podcasts we went ahead and purchased
financial peace university
and and went through that to help and we
still use the every dollar
app to this day for our budget and yeah
and all the baby steps from there so
very cool
very cool well thanks for plugging into
ramsey plus and doing all that i'm so
proud of you guys
very well done well that's how i'm like
you once somebody
convinces me of something i'm like okay
what's the plan right
what's the plan what's what's what's the
path i need the path just show me what
to do
and i'll go do it you know i'm not real
smart but i can go do that so
yeah so way to go you guys very very
well done
very well done what was the hardest part
of the last two years
um i would say just staying the course
you know the the first couple months are
fun and exciting because you're making
big progress
and then the last 16 months
are not that fun and exciting but if you
keep your goal out in front of you
and just stay the course stick with the
plan and
just don't give up yeah okay way to go
guys
it's awesome very very very well done
we've got a copy of the legacy journey
for you because that's the next chapter
in your story for sure
you've changed the legacy of your whole
family in the last two years
and 19 days you changed the whole
direction you're really powerful people
very well done heroes very well done
thank you
and i also got a copy of the total money
makeover for you you already have one
but i'm not giving it to you for you i'm
giving it to you so you can give it away
and pay it forward
and get someone else started and you can
be their cheerleaders
just like that guy that had the same
numbers as you and called in
and did his debt free scream and y'all
are doing yours today so very well done
i'm sure somebody's listening is going
to have the exact same numbers as you
that's the way this works guys it always
works this way it always works this way
nothing happens in a vacuum so cool yeah
very well done
all right heath and morgan columbus ohio
127 000 paid off in
two years and 19 days they did it on 108
to 123 000
income count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one where is that free
[Music]
[Applause]
i love it
now you gotta understand the math here
okay they got 108 000 coming in
and they paid off 50 000 a year and they
downgraded their car and they had two
little kids
and and that and after taxes that means
they lived on nothing
and she was a teacher during covet beans
and rice
rice and beans that's what they did and
if you're listening
you are out of excuses you're out
no more whining aloud you can't
they they lived on nothing so shut up
no more excuses yeah really they did
heath and morgan incredible
yeah that's just and but you know well
you know you know
i have my starbucks every day i can't
have a
i can't not go out to eat i mean what
kind of life would it be to not go on
vacation for two years
got rid of 127 thousand dollars worth of
debt it's a life of 50 years of going
wherever you want to go
hey there it is man good for you guys
so dr john delonie and rachel cruz will
be doing
another money and marriage live stream
one week from this friday that is on
july the 16th and it'll be a live
stream that's why we call it that it's
alive the two of them talking about
money and marriage they are
fun and we're funny up in the chaos this
time it's gonna be a hoot man and the uh
yeah i bet you're gonna have some fun
man it's only 20 to go through it
and uh you need to go ahead and get your
ticket now you can do that by texting
marriage 233 789
marriage to 33 789
or you could just go ahead and go over
to ramsey plus and
sign up for financial peace university
in ramsey plus and take a free trial
by the way if you're in ramsey plus you
guess what get to watch the if you're a
member
you get to watch the money and marriage
event as a part of your membership
and i have people ask hey can i watch if
i'm dating somebody of course can i
watch it if i'm not dating buddy i'm
just want to learn yes
it's a good time man it'll be fun yeah
it's going to be fun funny and it'll
actually
it's great pre-marriage counseling yeah
and it's great middle of marriage what
are we doing counseling
she's like yeah there you go
so the proven plan that is financial
peace university that's what they did
they went and signed up for it
and got out of debt and if you're a
member uh you do that at ramsey plus
and you're if you want a free trial of
that just text
trial 233 789 trial
two three three seven eight
nine this is the ramsey show
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host i'm dave ramsey your host thanks
for joining us
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five
two two five brian is with us brian's in
pittsburgh how are you brian
dave i'm good thanks for taking a minute
to talk with me my pleasure sir how can
we help
so i want to tell you uh about six weeks
ago
i ran into a friend of mine that retired
and he was telling me how great it was
and
asked me how much longer do you have i
said 12 years and
he started telling me get ready debt
free that's the only way to go
i hear him don't pay a lot of attention
to it my son
tells me a week after that hey i'm
listening to this ramsay show
never heard of it before i said what is
he new howard stern i don't know never
heard of
yes he is howard's got
much better hair than i've got yeah
uh so he tells me this a couple more
times i'm on a trip for work i got a lot
of windshield time i turn it on
i listen to six podcasts back to back to
back and i'm gonna tell you i'm hooked i
get it i'm i am bought in
wow so i heard you say hey you got to
know
everything that's going out everything
is coming in and what's your debt so i
did that
i spent about 30 hours on that last week
and let me tell you it's uh
scary it's emotional it was tough yeah
and
so i've got some debt and my question
for you
is i have about 12
000 and change that we have invested in
the stock market single stocks
and is it smarter to leave that there as
a savings i know there's a risk there
and or is it better to pull every penny
out of that
and put it towards the debt that we have
and that that might would take care of
uh
i don't know 20 25 of it
but my goal i mean i want to be debt
free i got 12 more years to retire and i
want to be debt free when we get there
and i wanted to do it i met my wife
bought in on it now
okay so you got about 50 000 worth of
debt and 12 000
in stock 66 247 to be exact
all right good deal what's your
household income
uh about 180 190 annually okay all right
so you've been listening and you know
some of the lingo now
and some of the process and the baby
steps and all of that right
and so baby step two is where you are
paying off all debt except the house
using the debt snowball listing your
debts smallest to largest
paying minimum payments on everything
but the little one attack the little one
we stop
all investing temporarily and we use
all money that we can get our hands on
that is not
in a retirement account to throw at baby
step two
and that's a standard baby step two
answer
which would lead us to cashing out your
stock and paying off a fourth of your
debt
okay not saving a lot you're when you
talk about emergency funds i mean leave
that there i mean we got no cash
saving how much cash
uh i don't know 11 12 grand something
like that okay we always baby step
one is one thousand dollars saved
anything above that
goes on baby step two until baby step
two is done and so i'm gonna use that
money as well down to one thousand
dollars which is going to scare the p
wadden out of you by the way
that scares the hell out of that i know
i know and that's it should
but you're not going to live there for
very long because
now we've paid off uh 23 000
of your 66 000 uh if i did my math right
just now
and you have enough income to clear the
rest of it very very quickly
and as soon as it's clear then the first
order of business is baby step
three and that's build your emergency
fund
back up to a full three to six months of
expenses
which it's not now it's kind of it's
kind of anemic right now it's weak
right the two together would make a
decent emergency fund if you didn't have
any debt but
that's what we teach and here's the
reason uh it's not to induce fear but
the fear will also help be one of your
motivators
that oh crap moment you just had that
thing where your stomach just kind of
jumped up in your throat just to the
mere suggestion of doing this and we
hadn't even done it
but just the idea you go you know we all
do that we all have a physical reaction
to that
um that is going to drive you to stick
with the plan
now to suggest that you keep a one
thousand dollar emergency fund for five
years or something would be ludicrous
and i don't suggest that
but we're talking about just a mere
months here again what was your
household income
uh 180 190. okay so how fast do you pay
off fifty thousand dollars
six months forty or no i'm sorry uh
forty thousand dollars
like what i mean less than six months
right
well my goal was two years i wanted to
do it before i'm 50. so that's that
sucks that's way too long
rocks you make 180 thousand dollars a
year
i need 40 000 of 180.
this is six months how much does this is
cloud 5000 i want 5 000
a month on this dad i want you to smack
the crap
out of it all right
and then you're so you're done by
christmas dude
now chris by christmas you're starting
to rebuild this emergency fund
from one thousand dollars up and then as
soon as you've got that three to six
months of expenses then you restart your
401k oh by the way you put money in the
401k right now
i took your advice and i backed it down
to the
minimum that the company matches okay
that wasn't my advice my advice was stop
it
i don't stop it all together i
misunderstood i thought you you were
saying
you know don't let free money go to the
company matches no
no no no when you're in the hole man
you're just getting started on all this
you're trying
so what i'm what i'm doing is i'm not
making fun of you and i'm not picking at
you but i'm giving you the
the the detail that you haven't gotten
in the last couple weeks of exposure
yet and so what i need to do is i'm
going to send you the the game plan
with all the nuanced detail the baby
steps on steroids it's the
best-selling book called the total money
makeover and we'll give it to you as a
gift
hold on kelly's going to pick up i'm
going to mail you one and you read that
thing and your wife read that thing
and you'll see what i'm talking about
180 minus 40
you can make it on okay or 90 minus 40.
90 in the next six months
minus 40 and you're done by christmas
you can make it on and i just
put 11 and 12 on the debt
so i know i put 23 out of there so it's
43 left
and so yeah you're there you're going to
be there
and that's that's what i would do if i
woke up in your shoes the
the the great news is you've you've
found a new thing here
and you're fired up about it but it's
about to get real that's right
so imagine you imagine this this is this
is the feeling you had brian when you
put you
spent 30 hours and you put that debt
down
and you got emotional that's you on
the plains of africa and you're a a
gazelle and you just stuck your head up
and you just saw that lion in the grass
and now you gotta take off running man
and that's what the next six seven
months is gonna be it's gonna be a
all-out gut-wrenching sprint because
cell intensity that's right
because they're coming for you man
they're coming you got to ride
i want to mention this i don't want this
to fly by dave i know this makes me
sound sappy
it takes a special level of courage for
a grown man making this kind of money
which means he's got some kind of
he's got some some ego some strength his
son
came in and said dad i think you should
look at this and most dads in this
situation go
shut up and he listened he just listened
that the approach on the call was humble
it was a humble call and i want
everybody out there if your son comes
says hey can we just talk dad
take that talk take that that breakfast
take that conversation man
um that took a lot of courage for a son
to do and i'm proud of him but i'm proud
of that dad for listening man that's
cool
yeah it doesn't happen very often cool
brunch gotta he's got a thing going
he does man he's comfortable on his own
skin
yeah strong but making good decisions so
yeah you're gonna you're gonna
go do this brian and and then you're
gonna call us back do your debt free
scream we're gonna hear a great story
from you it's gonna be awesome what i
love about brian is i guarantee he's a
leader
and as a leader he approached this with
the appropriate skepticism and then he
did the math
and then as a good leader he went oh
crap you know what i mean
that's a good leader man not that
everything's perfect not that i gotta
come up with some stupid excuse but i
can see the data and i can go whoops we
need to change course quick
right yeah i don't think i did that one
right i love it man i love it
that's this is there's a formula here
for everybody listening
yeah that that you know involves life
change
you know bible says be not conformed to
this world
yeah this world's broke yep i mean
normal
is looking good and no money yep normal
is you're driving a car with a
big butt payment on it normal is you got
a student loan that's been around so
long you think it's a pet
normal is you know you've discovered
master
card yes and discovered bondage in
american distress
this is normal normal sucks but it looks
good
everybody's walking around the smile on
their light on their faces
living in the land of denial and you
know i'm not talking about a river in
egypt
you know i mean seriously but when you
stick your head up and you go game on
baby
i'm not gonna be normal anymore be not
conformed to this world be
transformed by what brian's doing the
renewing of your mind
new information will set you free baby
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america we're so glad you're
here
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five dr john dolone ramsey
personality is my
co-host today uh we appreciate you guys
being with us jump in we'll talk about
your life and your money
you can hear dr john's show on uh as a
podcast and on youtube as well
uh it's a pod we put it out a couple
times a week and if you want to be a
caller on that you are more than welcome
we would love to have you participate
with him on that
and uh you can call and leave a
voicemail at 844-693-3291
or you can email ask john
ramseysolutions.com
uh his show's all about mental health
and about boundaries and about anxiety
and about dealing with uh all kinds of
relationship
issues and so he's here to answer your
questions about that kind of stuff today
as well as jump in on these other calls
and we'll just dive in
uh and do that but if you got a
particular question again triple eight
eight two five
five two two five join me right now
heather's in west palm beach hey heather
what's up
hey how are you dave nice to speak with
you today you too how can i help
uh so we have a house um and
um long story short it went into
foreclosure due to
some mistreatment of it was a bank of
america anyhow long story short
we have a modification but the interest
rate is at like a
five something and we have a balloon
payment at the end of i believe
eighty five thousand dollars and i just
wanted to know would you
advise trying to sell the house if i can
get out of it free and clear
or should we just stay the course
working to pay off the house and then
deal with that balloon at the end
well it sounds like it sucks on the
interest rate and you've got a ticking
time bomb in there
yes sir also do you have the ability to
refinance or is your credit destroyed in
this process
um no our credit is working back up a
few years ago we did
get on to the baby steps and we have
paid off all those credit cards and i've
closed them out
we've really done an amazing job can you
refinance the house
yes that was my next question do you
want to stop
do you want us um i don't want to stay
um but the situation that we're in you
know with work and everything it
we need to stay um so no
work does not demand you live in that
house
you've got you're allowing a lot of
other voices to speak into what you want
what do you want to do okay you want to
live in this house or not live in this
house
you are not as trapped as you think you
are
um i don't want to live in the house
okay i don't
sell it yeah sell the house it's a house
okay
there's another one down the street
i know i'm just i'm so nervous with the
housing market being crazy right now
that we wouldn't be able
you know especially where we live um we
you know houses are just flying you know
they're sold left and right before you
can even
get your foot in the door to take a look
it they're under contract
okay so you're gonna benefit from that
too that means you're gonna get premium
price for your house
yeah and if you have to rent for a
season while you heal you're not well
you haven't healed yet
you're still scanning every square inch
of your environment for somebody coming
to get you
and it makes it hard to make simple
decisions like i don't want to live in
this house anymore
i want to be able to sleep all day right
you're still on
high high alert what's your household
income my household income is around 120
thousand and how much debt do you guys
have not counting the house left
um 18. okay
and so what would the what would the
house uh how much money would you have
in your pocket
if you sold the house from the sale of
the house your equity
i'm looking at if i'm looking at you
know what the payoff would be
that's the problem that i'm having is
i'm looking at it like 20 000.
and to me i just i don't know that's
scary you know
well you make 120 000 a year you're 100
debt free when you sell this house you
got out of a bad interest rate with a
ticking time bomb
in a house you don't even like and you
go rent for 24 months let the market
cool off you guys
exhale and heal and have a good time
enjoy your life saving down the pain
up a down payment go by again game on
two years from today
and me and dave aren't that smart and we
just solved all your problems
in all seriousness there's something
about when you feel like
everything's breathing down your neck
it's hard to just get perspective
yes it is and you know my my husband if
i can interrupt really quick my husband
has a wonderful job
he loves his job immensely great um
great else i guess we would just have to
that's why we i would love to to
relocate to a different you know a
different state
but he loves his job and i'm very happy
that would be a different
discussion than we've been having
another conversation for another time
that's a conversation you have when you
know what if you all did that
leaving a rental property behind be
easier
that is very true so let's let's get
this part straightened out and then
let's make the decisions later on his
career
okay do you hate the house or you just
don't want to live in that town
anymore you want to move away i don't
want to i don't want to live in the town
i you know
to be honest with you is it the house i
mean i understand i understand
you're not leaving because he's got a
good job we've already established that
right at least now i love the house i
love the house and the fact that
it has everything um we're short a
bedroom but
that's not a big deal you know um but it
has things for the kids like it has a
pool so i mean
it is it's a great location it's central
to everything
i think i don't like the house because i
feel this mortgage is like the
great cloud factory that's right
okay well let me okay let's let's reset
then uh because i'm getting new
information that i didn't have earlier
all right so what would happen if um
you refinanced and you stay you promised
yourself we're gonna stay two years
i could totally do that and do you like
the house
then
probably not i'd probably move after two
years or now
after two years i mean if we could you
would move inside let's say your husband
kept his job would you move inside west
palm
no no no no
i wouldn't i i want to move so well
so heather let me tell you this your
husband loves his job and he's making
good money he's whatever
i promise you more than his job he wants
a spouse who
loves her life and i think you'll need
to have that conversation
yeah we're going to have to we're going
to pan back and make the decision on
this job in this west palm thing because
you're getting all this confused back
and forth that's right
every time i go around the barn you go
through a different door which
and so you just you're circling yourself
girl
so here's the thing if you're gonna stay
in the area and you like the particular
home
you would refinance period right
if you're not going to stay in the area
you would sell it and leave the area do
something and stop standing there
spinning yeah
this this back and forth with the
husband and i don't like west palm but i
sort of like the house but i don't like
the mortgaging but you got a ticking
time bomb on you
you do need to get rid of the mortgage
yes something needs to happen sell the
house or refinance one of the two
but you need to do one of the other
[Music]
me
still on baby step number one huh how'd
you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit chministries.org budget
don't worry it's worth it
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones a triple
eight eight two five two here at ramsey
solutions we're on a mission to
transform
so many lives that disruption spreads
like
wildfire through this toxic culture
so many things out there that need
changing and
we're in the business of helping people
change them so whether it's
your finances your career your mental
health
your marriage we're in these businesses
and we're here to
help you with the process if you want to
join us on this crusade
we are on the hunt for software
engineers with expertise in
ruby on rails java c-sharp
front-end technologies if you're a ux
designer
seo content marketing specialist data
analyst we uh we've got about 300
positions to fill
we currently have about 400 and some odd
of our 1 000 team members
that are tech because a lot of the stuff
we do is digital obviously
and so uh it's a complete technology
company
uh con you know uh concealed behind a
broadcast
so but uh if you guys have any interest
in that we'd love to have you we need
some help here
we're going to hire as i said about 300
folks this year and
if you're interested text the work to 33
789
and you can find out any of our
available jobs there's technology as
well as other things so lots and lots of
stuff going on
senior devs big time big time here
uh and so texting text the word work to
33789 and find out about all the
opportunities at ramsey
solutions our question of the day comes
from blinds.com find out for yourself
why blinds.com this great american
company is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings with free samples free
shipping and the new promos they run all
the time
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey to get the best
possible deal all right today's question
comes from
hannah in florida i am 21
married and a new parent to a son my
parents approached me recently about
funding their retirement because i quote
owe them there's been a lot of damage
done in the past and to be completely
honest i have lost respect for them
well no kidding i'm unsure how to handle
this too
i just met him yeah i'm uninviting them
to my birthday just on this
i'm not sure enough for you mom how to
handle this and where to go with the
relationship
um i think the famous song says get that
dirt off your shoulder
brush it off and move on i don't know
what to say man um you don't owe your
parents retirement
god um yes there's clearly been a lot of
damage done and now they're circling
back
for round two round seven yeah
at this point you need to be confident
and strong you've got a new family
and unfortunately um the old saying goes
not by your hand but in your lap
somebody put a grenade in your lap and
you've got to deal with it
and that means you've got to be the
adult in the situation and
i think i think there's a here's how i
approach this dave
she gets the opportunity to demonstrate
how an adult handles problems and so it
could be easy to say i'm going to block
him never talk to him again
and what that does is it shoves that
problem in a in a box and throws it in
the ocean but
there's it's the problem still there i
think she reaches out
probably in writing and says i'm not
going to do this and by the way
me and my husband have talked about
boundaries and here's how we're moving
forward
um this is so toxic and so gross i don't
even know what to do with it
um but it is what it is and those
parents do exist
um proof you don't have to pass a test
to be a parent right um
because some of you people would flunk
all right now and start again
but um wow uh
so yeah pick up henry cloud's book
boundaries honey
uh because you're gonna have to learn to
set them and you're 21 years old
and it's not fair that this is coming at
you
your your parents are weird um
you don't owe them a retirement
and um what you can do is just lovingly
but
very strong say smile
calm no yelling no screaming no cussing
uh just um no we don't owe you a
retirement and no we're not doing that
what we owe you is to love you and we do
that
we love you and we cheer for you and we
hope it works out for you good
we hope you do well and we'll be
cheering for you
and um you know if you're ever hungry
holler
and we'll make you a meal you can come
over and hang out as long as you behave
while you're here that's right
but um you don't have to cut them out of
your life you don't have to hold them
back
now i will warn you this okay when
people that don't have good boundaries
i.e your parents okay eg
your parents um people that don't have
good boundaries when you give them
boundaries
they generally don't like it they flip
out so
do not expect this to go like oh darling
i'm sorry i never thought about it that
way no
these are people that are going to go
you're ungrateful we pay for this
travel agent for guilt trips and that's
what they're going to be
so you know no don't expect anything but
them to go cray-cray on you
and just because something is
uncomfortable or just because something
breaks your heart doesn't mean it's the
wrong thing
expect them to come back and make you
sad to hurt your feelings
to be immature morons and
you still did the right thing because we
kind of have established that they are
that
wow already i'm trying to put myself in
a situation where i would
can you imagine calling rachel and
daniel in it's hey guys listen um
me and your mom remember that time i
bought you diapers
you owe me i've done the math and
remember that time i fed you
you owe me you remember that time i
you know just whatever you know did
whatever for you like i did what my
parents would do
yeah but you now owe me i can't wrap my
head around that conversation
yeah and it's just ah man i'm sorry that
you're going through this hand
it's heartbreaking and honey this is not
going to be easy
and it's not going to be over quick but
the answer is you don't owe them
and you have to gently and kindly say no
all i owe you is to love you and i will
pay that debt
and she points to it i know this isn't
the first time you've been put in a
situation with him it won't be the last
time that's why
dave's recommendation that book
boundaries practice with you and your
husband y'all come up with some
rules of the road for your new family
and stick to them man
yeah and and then you decide how much
access they have to your kid
because are they going to misbehave
around your kid you know and that's what
you're going to be facing yeah
so it's it's harsh and it's what's
sadness
what's sadness john you have a big
career ahead of you
hey man there's a lot of people in
america that need you
tell you what david is in waco texas hi
david how are you
good hi mr ramsey hi dr d thanks for
having me great how can we help um so
mike
yeah my question is i got a house
question for you guys
my grandfather did well in his career
and lived well below his means
so he set up a trust account for each of
his grandchildren me included
so currently the trust account is about
1.1 million dollars
and so one of the reasons or one of the
few ways that i can use the trust
account before age 40
isn't buying a house and so my wife and
i are currently looking at buying a
house
and so i was just wondering you know how
much would you spend from the trust on
that house
and then also i just wanted to confirm
that you would buy that house in full
using the money oh absolutely i pay cash
for it
no doubt about it what's your household
income
so it was 120 last year um i'm gonna
take the year off to get a master's
degree in accounting
and so my wife's income is going to be
50 000
so then once i get my degree then it'll
go back up
okay i don't know why you have to take
time off to get a master's in accounting
you can do that in the evenings yeah
every single one of my grad degrees
was working full-time but that's a
different phone call i guess
here's what i would tell you in in there
in waco you can
buy a house that is 185 000 that's a
remarkable home and then you can go
bananas
and buy a million dollar house so what
are you thinking about spending
yeah so our we were thinking somewhere
you know i don't know in 300 range
our total max would be 400 we don't want
to do more than that but
i think that's fine pay cash for it and
then uh but i'm also
going to challenge you to rethink taking
a year off i think you just go to class
in the evenings and finish your masters
yeah in accounting
um but i'm without getting into the
detail of it i'm
just i'm just challenging you to rethink
that i'm with you i think it'll be
better for everybody
yeah but aside from that 120 150 000
income 400 000 are paid for house out of
the trust makes sense oh make sure
you're paying yourself a house payment
after that
now so that you become wealthy like your
grandpa that'd be an idea
forward this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
all right they're here in the lobby of
ramsey solutions on the debt free stage
shawn and kim are with us hey guys how
are you good how are you doing
better than i deserve welcome where do
you guys live san antonio right now
all right fun fun well good looking
family how much debt have you guys paid
off
uh 139 500 good for you and how long did
that take
uh six months going davish and another
24 months uh fully focused
got it and your range of income during
that 30 months
about 110 000 to 190 000. whoa
nice jump what do you guys do for a
living
i'm in the army and i'm a schoolteacher
awesome very cool well thank you for
your service
what caused the uh jumping income to
almost double
school teacher school teacher i i got a
job i was a stay-at-home mom
oh you went into the world he was two so
yes okay
what do you teach uh third grade
currently wow thank you for your service
yeah thank you yeah i think you might
have a harder job
i think so not the third graders they're
precious it's their stupid parents
wow so way to go so honored to have you
what kind of debt was 140 000
almost everything you can think of so we
had three
three car loans a boat loan um
student loan a personal loan two credit
cards
uh those were pretty big um i think that
was about everything but medical debt
and
two cell phones also y'all were like
normal yep
that was awful yes it was man that's
just amazing
how long you guys been married 10 years
15 15 years yeah okay
now i'm now 15 but uh just a little over
10 when you did that
started this thing 30 months ago two and
a half years ago so 12 years yeah right
so
after 10 12 years of marriage you look
up and go
hey this plan is not working what
happened tell me the story
well we've actually done this a couple
of times so um
like through deployments you know we
would come back kind of uh
free of credit card debt and get
ourselves to a comfortable place and
then we would kind of fall back into
that same routine
so that was kind of a habit that we
started doing
um but then we got davis a little while
he had gone to
uh through the chaplain services on um
onpost they were offering the was it the
financial people
university yes yeah yeah the military
version has taught
millions so pretty cool so i started
taking that and uh
like like kim said we had been in and
out of debt uh however
we never thought of paying off all the
cars and having that and no credit cards
at all it was
i'd pay the credit card off while
deployed and i'd i'd save up some money
and then i'd come home and i'd think
about uh you know all the money that i
just saved and we'd spend it all so
for example the last deployment i got
home uh we paid off all the credit card
debts
still had all the car loan i thought
that was normal and then i bought six
thousand dollars worth of dogs
uh two dogs just blew everything that we
saved
yep two dogs what kind of dogs uh an
english massive
we were in italy at the time so i got an
english mastiff from hungary
and uh tamaskin from from england of
course you did yep
and they were thousands each apparently
spent everything and then
got right back into debt that sounds so
much like something i would do
that's awesome and sharon's looking just
like her she's looking at me like i've
lost my mind you did
what you bought dogs of course they were
they were surprises to kim you know
yeah yeah wait till you hear the car
story though
yeah go ahead which one oh the birthday
present mm-hmm
oh good was watching too many lexus
commercials where are you
put a big red bull jack actually i did
exactly
i did that one time too i did it too one
time
but it was a range rover
wow yeah we don't go big unless we you
know
we don't go unless we go big this is
awesome you guys are fun
what a mess that was our second round
over though it was we sold the
sold the first one after after we had
this guy and we bought a third row
i thought that was better yeah yeah you
needed one here got rid of the uh
the first range rover and then i thought
oh she still needs one so i okay
so you're in financial peace university
and this thing like i get
it's like me with a two before smashing
you in the face i guess
and you came home and you told her we're
gonna do it again uh yes but much
different i i went through a lot of the
classes that
that you know i was learning all the
things that i was learning from you and
and told her
uh some of the new lessons that i had
learned you know
no car debt was was a big one uh cutting
up the credit cards completely i
i kind of knew that rule but i just
never did it so
um so kim what was your reaction when
you start saw this
um you think it was here we go again no
i didn't actually
um you know we had heard about about you
and the
programs and um what we could eventually
achieve
and so i actually it was my suggestion
that we
get rid of my um my birthday present
because that was just a huge hindrance
you know preventing us from
really like attacking our goals so
once we did that um that really kind of
put us on a better track so
that was uh probably a point of no
return from me when when she said hey
we probably need to sell this because i
was we were a couple months in this was
the davish time couple months in i was
clinging on to that because it was a
birthday present for us i felt really
bad getting rid of it
i actually sold my uh 2002
camaro z28 that i had for 11 years i
sold that
so i could have a little bit of cash to
keep her uh her truck
wow so getting rid of her truck was like
the the final that's when the
point broke loose we're not going back
what about the dogs did you sell them oh
we still have them okay i'm glad the
dogs made it
john just so you know john he thought
about selling you before you got rid of
that v28
he thought about it can i keep the
camaro and get rid of one of the three
yeah the teenager could go the teenager
could go keep the car yeah
[Laughter]
oh you guys so what do you tell people
the secret to getting out of debt is now
that you've done it
um that's a good question
um i don't know i think just basically
being on the same page having a goal
and really like having a vision and
sticking to it
um i know personally for me it was
really
easy when i would look at do i really
want to shop or do i really want this
dream house like i was trying to look at
what our what we wanted our future to
look like
and you know after retirement we would
look at homes and i would show them all
these ones i wanted and he was like
uh i won't be able to afford that and i
was like excuse me
like maybe i don't need those shoes so
um you know just
keeping an eye on your end goal and
working together
like we always communicated about
everything we were always on the same
page with everything
so that really helped for me i think
a lot of people say the budget and uh
for for a decade
plus i was very meticulous with a budget
i'm that excel spreadsheet guy
who uh who has every number you know
accounted for and everything it's just
that i was including debt
into it so i it was it was fine we were
on a budget but we were still using
those credit cards
so sticking to a budget and having the
right budget
is key but um getting rid of the credit
cards was probably one of the big things
for me i cut them all
up closed all the accounts and i think
that was the first
the first uh big step not having that
safety net
and that the safety net was the thousand
dollars the baby step one
and then and then building that safety
net you know bigger and bigger
uh so that the safety net becoming cash
rather than a credit card
was a big yeah if you have a drinking
problem you have to get all the alcohol
out of the house
you know that's what it amounts to and
that's what you finally did it i mean
you finally took that
scissors and had plastic surgery and
that that that was a breakthrough that
was emotional
yeah when you did that very good
congratulations you guys how's it feel
thank you sir
feels great liberating was it was it
worth it
absolutely for sure i wish i wish i
could go back in time and uh
and kick my 20 year old butt and i have
started a lot earlier
but yeah don't we all yeah and so kim
yes will you ever go back absolutely not
will you allow him to i don't think
we'll allow each other to
you know good answer better answer than
me baiting you okay
and the next time you can just go to the
pound for 30 bucks
oh my god you haven't seen these dogs
both of them are beautiful animals i
mean they're incredible they're
incredible animals but i think i got out
of the hospital for less than three
thousand dollars with both my kids
i'm just saying yeah you did all right
count it down guys 140 000
paid off in six months and uh 30 months
rather making 110 to 190 count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
[Music]
three two one
love it yeah
[Music]
[Music]
dr john delaney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
two steve is in kansas city hi steve
welcome to the ramsey show
hi there gentlemen thank you for having
me how are you today better than we
deserve sir what's up
i have a question about buying your car
when you drive
for a living at a very expensive amount
of miles
how many miles a year are you driving um
i drive about 14 000 a month
so i think that's right around almost
150 000 a year
good lord whoa when do you get out of
the car
you must live in the thing i i do
actually when i'm on the road i
do live in it wow what do you do
i deliver uh campers from the
manufacturer to
dealers all across america
okay so this is a vehicle that has to
tow
yes yes those are towing miles okay
all right wow and what do you make of
here
um this is my first year doing it but
i'm on pace to make just under six
figures
okay and uh are these contracts or
as an employee i'm i'm 10.99 so it's my
own personal vehicle and i work when i
want to i choose where i go
it's a great job but it's it's crap on
vehicles
yeah for sure okay so
uh you you own a business
that uh it's a one-person business but
you then
you know let's put that in perspective
and part of your expense of operating
your business is you destroy a vehicle
once a year
correct and so we've got to budget that
in and so
what we want to do is destroy
the least number of dollars possible and
still get the job done
does that make sense yes sir it's an
expense of running a business so what
we're going to do when we get the job
done
at the least possible expense and so i
don't buy the fanciest obviously
uh i buy the least thing because
whatever it is i'm gonna lose the money
so
uh do we wanna you know will a ten
thousand dollar truck get this job done
maybe probably a twenty thousand dollar
truck
you don't need a thirty thousand dollar
truck
right well the the only well the only
stipulation to that is
it has to be a diesel vehicle you cannot
be leased on with
any company you're not allowed to pull a
camper with less than a three-quarter
ton
diesel and new you know those are
running 60 to
you know 60 000 plus yeah yeah you don't
buy them
i mean even even used one is 30 grand
plus
okay so if if you buy a 30 000
one and you put 110 000 miles on it
what's it worth after that
well with the market right now it's
right around probably 20 ish
it would only go down 10 000 for putting
a hundred and ten thousand miles on it
in one year
with a with a market the way it is now
with the computer chip issue
and everything yes they're holding their
value a ton not that
that's not right you're wrong
they're not holding you do not lose only
ten thousand dollars in value putting
110 000 miles on a 30 000
truck that's just not right dude you're
not operating with real information here
okay that truck's worth 10 after you're
done with it at most
and i know the market's hot and i know
there's computer chip issues and i know
trucks are hot
and i know the used car market's hot i'm
on top of over a bit of that it's part
of what we do around here but
i do not think that cut truck only went
down ten thousand dollars but
so the bottom line though is it's going
to go down between 10 and 20 000
well we can agree on that you think 10 i
think 20. so somewhere in there is
probably right
um and so that's what it's going to cost
you
every year if you buy a 30
and you sell it for 15 it costs you 15
000
and you buy another 30 and you sell it
for 15 it's going to cost you 15 000
and if you can do that every year that's
your formula if that will get the job
done and be reliable and i
i think it'll be reliable but i would
try to do it cheaper
i'd try to buy a 25 and sell it for
15. i'll buy 30 and keep it for two
years or three years well i don't yeah
if it's diesel and you you maintain it
maybe you can put 200 50 000 miles on in
two years and
and then see what it's worth and see how
much you lose but the bottom line is how
can we run this formula where you lose
the least
money and still get the job done
and don't get into the rationalization
of this uh because this is a business
expense that's all it is and the problem
is you spend so stinking much time in it
that every little thing that goes wrong
with it every little tiny thing
is going to be magnified in your
emotions
and and it's going to cause you to lose
your your judgment but just pretend like
you are running a
fleet you are a fleet manager how can i
run this business
for the least possible expense thereby
increasing my profit the most
and so the most you ought to spend is
30. i can tell you that
and i try to get the job done for less
than that dave help me with this
so i can imagine being a 50 year old man
and i'm just making up a number how old
this guy is um looking for work
i find this job i sit down and meet with
them they map it out for me and suddenly
i'm making 90 000 a year feels
incredible
and i take the job and then here's all
the stuff that comes with it
i can imagine not doing the math and
sitting down saying okay i got to buy a
30 000
truck it's going to cost me 10 grand in
gas
it's going to cost me ten grand or five
grand in eating and meals on the road
suddenly this ninety thousand dollar job
can really quickly turn into a 45 or 50
000 year job of which there may be more
locally
right is that a bad way to look at this
no that's sick that's actually very
accurate
you have to run a p l on this business
you can get real excited about this
this bottom number but your top number
is doesn't matter
except to the extent it affects your
bottom number you know and so
and it takes your soul from you that
many days on the road
yeah you're out there by yourself a long
time you're a truck driver yeah
and so i mean you're gone and over the
road
and so uh yeah you've got the cost of
the loss in value
got the cost of the operation and uh and
you've got the
additional costs that you wouldn't have
at home for food
or hotels or whatever now you say you
stay in the truck probably yeah it's
going to take showers you got
you know and the gasoline prices all
that stuff diesel prices but you're
hitting you're in the truck stops and
that's what he's doing but you do have
to say i'm gonna keep an
accurate number here because you can get
enamored with a hundred thousand that's
right
and if you don't take all these other
numbers off and get down to the reality
which is
you know it's probably 50 or 60 grand
right is what it is and i always want
somebody to look at that against
like being a manager of a fast food
restaurant and make a 50 grand that's
down the street from you right
it may not have the same prestige but
man if you look it on paper
is it is it dollar for a dollar very
similar right yeah
and so it it's yeah
and but you're self-employed yeah and
you have to be careful oh plus you got
to pull out thirty percent of it
here's the thing too you if you if you
mess this up emotionally and the
subject of his call what car do i buy
and you buy a sixty thousand dollar new
oh man and you turn that into 25 in one
year or 30 in one year
now you've lost 30. i didn't think about
that 90 grand
you got to pull 30 out for taxes because
you're self-employed on a 1099.
so you're down everybody's got taxes
that's right you don't have taxes either
way
but you're down to six i mean it just
feels like it goes pretty quick
it's um the taxes will be on the net
profit not on the
number but still just the same you you
gotta you'd have to manage the taxes as
well
and you do have an extra uh
self-employment tax
you pay both sides of five yeah yeah and
so there is it is
because the government loves small
business they love them so he taxes more
that's right so uh but anyway the uh all
of that does figure in but you got to be
real careful because
when you're that engaged in something
and we run into it around here where you
know
the computer guys come in and tell us we
need these computers
and when your hammer everything looks
like a nail right and i'm going
uh but that that's a lot of money right
and it's like real money because we
don't borrow money and it's like my
money
and so tell me again how we how else we
can do that job
cheaper be caught without doing that
because this doesn't sound like minimal
functional to me
this sounds like you just pitched me a
bentley
and not a minimal car that gets the job
done and so um we hit you know but when
your computer guy
or the answer to everything's computer
yeah you know and when you're a tech not
when you're
audio guy they answered everything's
audio well your car guy everything let's
start with bentley and work backwards
when you're on the road in your car all
the time and you if you don't if you're
not real careful you can as a small
business person you can eat up your
profits
by your by by your uh toys that you're
buying that's a good way to put it yeah
that's that's what you're creating
that's what happens all the time do the
math is what i'm saying you're right
you're right
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
ten nine eight seven
six five four three
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america we're so glad you're
here
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five
noah is with us in phoenix arizona
hi noah welcome to the ramsay show dr
john deloney is my co-host today how can
we help
hey there dave thanks for taking my call
sure um
hey uh so i um
my family my parents helped me out we
actually just moved down from washington
about seven months ago eight months ago
and um
my family helped me buy a house in um in
arizona and the housing market is so
much cheaper here um
so uh i uh they actually recently just
decided to
purchase they also purchased a house
down here and so they also recently just
decided to
um build a new house um in the same city
and so they're gonna be
uh they actually co-signed with me for
this
house that they help me buy um and they
want to refinance to get the
house off their um sorry to get the
loan off their off
their their back so then um it'll just
be on my name and then they can have
more room for
whatever they're doing um i'm curious if
i should
possibly sell the house or
like when we refinance because the house
has already made a bunch of positive
equity
or if i should uh refinance like they
say
how old are you i'm 25.
and you said we are you married i'm no
i'm
i'm
sorry my probably just me no okay all
right and so you
you bought a house and how much do you
owe on the house
uh i actually it's about two uh 247 so
247 thousand
okay and what do you make um
so i did the math here um i
actually have renters i have i live in
the house i live in one of the rooms um
two of the renters also live now i'm not
counting the renters what is your income
sir
oh without the renters it's uh it's
about it's only oh
after tax is about 33 000 before taxes
about 39
000. what do you do for a little with
renters it's about forty six thousand
after that
well let me help you with this you make
thirty three thousand dollars a year you
can't afford a 250
house
you can't afford you can't afford the
house
you can't refinance it you won't qualify
for the loan
you understand yeah i get you not even
close
when you make forty thousand dollars a
year you cannot qualify for a 250 000
mortgage
got it because the payment is as much as
you make man
well that yeah it is and um
and i've and i i checked it out so if i
did not have renters i would
and i'm already um if i did not have
renters i would be paying
um i would be breaking about even but
because i have renters i'm
i'm also paying for college on on top of
this so about it's about yeah but the
mortgage company when you go to
refinance will not qualify you based on
renters
they will not use they will not use you
renting out the bedroom as a way to
pay your bill when your payment is equal
to your income
i would sell the house and take equity
and pay for college
yeah you need to sell the house and go
rent something really cheap yourself
and finish up college and get your
income up and then talk about buying
later
and this is going to be a hard
conversation because your parents
probably gave you some stuff
your parents are out of their dadgum
minds yeah
to put you in this mess to start with to
have assisted you to get into this trap
i mean dude if your roommates don't pay
one month
you don't even eat if you pay your house
payment
this is this is cray cray these this
mathematics
math on this is nuts yeah so yeah you
you have really stepped deep into a hole
here
and even for them to have to get off of
a cosine so that they can
buy a second house and build it versus
they're playing a shell game too man
yeah
it sounds like they're in a mess
themselves but that's a that's another
story
but yeah for you you're 25 years old
you're going to college
you're making 35 000 39 000 a year
you know sell the house get the equity
pay for your college cash and
get go make sure you're debt free stay
debt free
do everything you can to get your income
up be studying something in college that
causes your
income income to go up uh don't don't
study some
left-handed puppetry degree then when
you have a when you have kids
you can buy them a house outright not
just co-sign for them
good grief man later on but yeah mom and
dad love you thank you
no because you can't refinance it
even if you want to no mortgage company
is going to give you this loan
and they shouldn't because you can't pay
it
tanya is with us in amarillo texas hi
tanya how are you
hey dave hey dr dalony how are you great
how can we help
good um my family is facing a big move
it's a good move but it's a little bit
scary
um we're moving to our to my husband's
family's farm to
um start taking over as his parents just
hire
it's across states we currently live in
texas and we'll be moving to oklahoma
we recently paid off all debts and we'll
be selling a house with
um a good amount of equity so my
question really is how can i
go about doing a good job of estimating
what our expenses might be
as we step into baby step number three
and then secondly
we kind of jumbled all the baby steps by
paying off the mortgage and
and moving in babes at two and now we're
at three and
being kids in college and so i just um
that's the very primary question is is
there a good way to estimate expenses
when you just don't know
i know cost of goods will be decreased
but taxes will be quite different
both income and retail and grocery
so i don't know how to estimate that i
don't think oklahoma is that different
from texas
well i've ordered groceries a few times
for my husband while he's there and it
it's the groceries tax is going to be i
just i'm afraid that's going to creep up
on us but yeah
not like you thank you no it's not that
much different i think
i think whatever your household expenses
are now is probably a good place to
start for estimating your household
expenses there
uh plus or minus whatever you're going
to change with the move but
in terms of oklahoma cost of living
versus texas cost of living
yeah unless you're moving from like
a major metro area in dallas you know
dallas or houston or something and
you're moving to a rural area in
oklahoma it might go down some
but food cost is not going to be
appreciably different utility cost is
not going to be appreciably different
um really no other there's nothing
that's going to be
substantially different the real estate
prices may be different in the areas
that you're going in but you're not even
dealing with that because you're moving
on to a family farm i think it's a
spiritual issue dave
when you race in texas you know that
oklahoma's the enemy and she's moving
into enemy territory and i think she's
just not sleeping
at night that's what i think
[Music]
all my hearts with you honey listen
his name is dr john deloney you can find
him
on social media and respond to that i
don't want to hear about it
this is the ramsey show
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
ten nine eight seven
six five four three
[Music]
thanks for joining us america this is
the ramsey show dr john dalony ramsey
personality is my
co-host imagine what your income could
do for you if it wasn't going out the
door every month in debt payments credit
card bills student loans
car payments yeah kind of takes your
life away doesn't it
you know what it'd be cool to be without
all that wouldn't it
it doesn't have to be doesn't that be
like this it doesn't take as long as you
think to get out of debt
people do it pretty quick once they get
on a plan it all starts with financial
peace university this is the class
that's helped
millions and millions of people learn
the proven plan to get out of debt
and build wealth but it's not enough to
just learn the plan you've got to put it
into action every single day
and the way you do that is by budgeting
with every dollar the world's best
budgeting app
and you can get financial peace
university and every dollar
only with a ramsey plus membership
a lot of other stuff at ramsey plus as
well but that's where a lot of people
get started
you can create a life for your mo where
your money works for you
and not against you it's time to get out
of the debt
fast and for good
start your free trial of ramsey plus
by texting trial to 33 789 text
trial 233 789
matthew is in tucson arizona hi matthew
welcome to the ramsey show
all right thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
i have a question for you guys it's a
kind of a
dock to vote situation i
am in the air force reserves as a
federal civilian doing the same job and
i'm looking at doing
transitioning into the chaplain corps
for the air force and
uh they have a program that will help me
with my master of divinity
and getting experience and stuff like
that but by entering the program
i lose my civilian position
because it's tied to my enlisted
position in the reserves
so i'm trying to figure out when would
be the best way
to kind of step over to the boat while
i'm working out my
finances okay
so you are in your you have another job
other than
the national guard right so yeah i'm uh
i'm an air force reservist and i am an
air reserve technician so during the
week i'm a federal civilian and on one
weeks per month two weeks out of the
year um
um enlisted but it's the exact same job
aircraft mechanic okay so you're you're
a civilian aircraft mechanic now
correct okay but you're wanting to drop
that you're wanting to drop that
which pays how much um
about 79 a year yeah so you're gonna
drop an 80 thousand dollar your job
to go as a full-time reservist or still
be a part-time reservist
so um i am
it's a complicated position because it's
i'm both right now but i'd be stepping
off from enlisted
to commission so
by going to commission i would finish
school with this program
and then after two years there's a
possibility of
me being able to go active duty
afterwards but it would be a two to
three year
um where is it you're trying to end up
i want to be an active duty chaplain in
order to provide
a lot of help for individuals in the
service that
good you don't have to have an mdiv to
do that
okay chaplaincy in the military does not
require an mdiv
um it does but no it doesn't a lot of
them aren't even christians
a lot of them are chaplains and they
have a completely different belief
they're hindu
they're muslim they're everything else
and they certainly don't have an mdiv
it's a masculinity or equivalent is what
the
requirement on the site says okay i
think you need to do some more
investigation we work with champions all
over the world
in the military they're the ones that
run financial peace university in the
military
and um and i've spoken to the groups uh
they're very diverse and uh they're very
uh
in their faith base and everything else
uh
and it's not a i i
i'm not a hundred percent sure but i'm
pretty sure that
that there's a lot of those folks i've
met that are not that are not masters
degreed
right and when and it says equivalent
that could be any sort of seminary like
or denominational whatever oh i guess it
could be a masters in finance for all i
know if it's a master's level he's
saying because i'll guarantee you they
don't have a
master's in theology if you're
uh you know if you're a practicing hindu
i mean you know or wiccan or whatever
else i mean i've met
chaplains that have just about every
kind of faith yeah
and in the military and so uh the public
has this perception that the chaplaincy
is all the guy on mash and it's father
so and so right it's not
okay it's not um because i made the
mistake i thought i was talking to a
bunch of preachers
christian preachers when i went in there
and they're like looking at me like i
had one eye in the center of my head
because i was i was jesus this jesus
that right and yeah and all of a sudden
i found out what jesus said and what all
of them are doing
gotcha so it was it was kind of a little
awakening for me i
kind of stepped in it's what i did but
um because i was because i was ignorant
of the
of how that how the chaplaincy in the
military works it's um
it's it's very interesting but it's not
what i had the perception that it was
i thought it was father whatever his
name is on mash you know i thought
that's what it was right
but anyway it's not so anyway i i think
you need to do a little more
investigation into that
and um i think you could
probably get into the chaplaincy program
and
the military would cover your masters
while you're full-time military if you
enlisted
that's what i've never heard of somebody
going to say hey you know what i want to
stop this
this part-time gig this weekend gig i
want to go full time and list and then
be told no
right i've never heard that it may exist
but if you want to go full on list my
understanding is they'll they're well
they're happy to take you yeah i think
they'll take you but the question is can
they plug him in and pay for the masters
and plug him into the chaplaincy program
straight up i'm not positive of that
but i think that could be arranged with
a recruiter yeah i really do i think
they would
enjoy your help um big time
and so uh but no i'm not gonna walk out
and of an eighty thousand dollar
position
uh down to part time or no time
uh and and to go to grad school full
time for two years in order to end up in
the chapel and see in the military
that's
you know there's there's gotta be
another route another path to get there
that is going to be much more palatable
on your checkbook yeah
but he did bring up something that i
think is important sometimes when you're
looking at these job requirements you
spend a lot of time
a on your head and b on the internet and
that's
it's like our it's what ken says ken
coleman says you got to go sit down with
somebody who's doing this job and say
give me the path
what is my point from a to b yeah and
they can help you yes they may tell you
dave ramsey isn't nothing don't know
what he's talking about it does require
a masters i they may tell you that but i
my experience with them does not
indicate that
yeah that's just uh and i've actually
had lots and lots and lots of
conversations with lots and lots of
chaplains
uh over the last 20 years yeah i mean
they're they're in here every week just
about somebody stopping in and
um i've been to their their their
gatherings and everything else i don't
know what to call it but um
you know but but so we love military
chaplains
we love the military and we really love
military chaplains they got a special
job
special calling so very interesting all
right open phones at triple eight eight
two five
five two two five you guys jump in dr
john deloney is my co-host today
and uh we'd love to have you participate
with us here
uh why does counseling have such a
negative connotation reid wants to know
oh man i think it's probably a holdover
from the old days that only crazy people
needed to go see somebody or see a
shrink
right and which comes from witch doctor
shrinking heads
right that's where that comes from yeah
it's head shrinker there's a
i think our parents grew up in a world
where uh you only went if you were quote
unquote
nuts right or something was crazy i look
at counseling now it's it's a set of
it's a set of skills a set of tools i
don't have right
it's a teacher and you sit down and
someone can hold up a mirror and reflect
you back to you and
be if you call it life coach it becomes
okay
that's right or if you call it a
hardware store i gotta go with some
different tools
it becomes really okay yeah i'm not sure
why it has a negative connotation unless
it's hauled over from that though i
agree that's all i can think of
yeah this is the ramsey show
ten nine eight seven
six five four three
[Music]
so
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today cara
is with us in sacramento california hi
kara how are you
hi dave thank you for taking my call
sure what's up um
i am just extremely overwhelmed i guess
is the best
way to see it um i'm a single mom i grew
up also with a single mom
and who struggled i'm definitely not as
bad as
off as i was growing up um but i am
still
struggling and i i know you're gonna say
i have an income problem i'm pretty sure
um i've my friend just introduced me to
you so i've been like
for the last few weeks listening to the
podcast and
you know like sometimes i'm like i got
the answer right i knew what you were
gonna say but i just can't handle my own
mess for some reason
um i just um i filed bankruptcy in 2019
because
a creditor was going to take 25 of my
wages
um and at one point i tried to put 10
percent in my retirement and i didn't
have enough for rent so i knew 25
was like a no-go so i did file
bankruptcy i did open
a couple credit cards after just to
build my credit
which now i know is a bad thing but um i
don't use them i
put a small amount i pay it right off i
was literally just trying to build my
credit i don't want a fiasco
um my rent is going up again in august
um
i just i don't know what to what to do
i'm terrified i have like
how old is your babies um well they're
actually
pretty much grown my youngest or my
oldest will be 24 in august and my
oldest
youngest will be 17 in august
and i'm 40. and you've raised them
completely by yourself
for the most part yeah my youngest one
her dad
we he's basically raised both of them we
started getting my oldest one was five
months old so
he's her dad the only guy she knows but
um
yeah he's been in the picture the last
probably since she was
nine and been like continually in the
picture so
you've been part you've been an
unmarried mother of children
yes their whole life and i yeah
yeah and i stopped them
stop a minute okay you're a freaking
hero
yeah you're amazing thank you
and you're exhausted i
am exhausted i mean i'm fortunate that
my job i'm a surgical technologist so
i'm
able to pick up extra shifts and call
and for many years i worked six or seven
days a week
and now enough you've not known how to
do anything for 20 years
except put out fires yeah
basically yeah and i've heard you twice
he gets tired
i've heard you twice on this call try to
try to minimize
what you're doing yeah but i'm really
lucky and yeah i know it could be worse
and yeah i know
you are doing hero work
and you've almost got it done i mean
you're almost done it was totally
amazing
okay so so let's let's open the next
chapter let's open the next chapter and
make it awesome
together okay yes i'm so proud of my
girls every
now they are very financially conscious
and you're not proud of your girls i'm
proud of you i'm proud of you
yes thank you all right so what do you
make of yours
um i my brain home is about
41. um it varies because and i just
recently started taking out
more shifts like a mad woman again but
so what are you 45
44 yes oh pretty good guess almost like
i've done this okay
yeah it's time or two huh all right so
okay
so you're a 45 year old uh single lady
whose kids are grown
yeah ha okay now yeah so for the next
20 years of your life 25 years of your
life
uh you get to have what we call an
encore
where you come out on the edge of the
stage after the play's over and you take
a bow and then you go again
so now now let's just start fresh let's
pretend we're 18
or were 45 and we got a white board
where do you want to be
who do you want to be what do you want
to be doing when you're 65
um i want to not be afraid to retire
i'm talking about your career yeah oh my
career i
i absolutely love my job i love being a
surgical tech i would love to
go and finish i would love for you to
make twice as much money as you make so
what are we going to do me too
nursing her pa is always been my goal oh
no
we're talking all right yeah i like that
one that's a good goal
so what are we going to tell you what
steps are we going to take to be a pa
how are we going to do this
um go back to school
yeah go back to school and i i mean i
don't feel like
will the place you work for pay for it
um well they'll do tuition reimbursement
you know that's kind of like paying for
it yeah
it's awesome yeah yeah i'm liking our
plan
already once you get to a certain point
you have to have
be able to support yourself and do it
because you can't work full-time anymore
with that
i know but listen you're already you're
already you're already setting up
roadblocks
and we're just going to pull them or we
can do this for hours we're going to
keep pulling them out so let me tell you
what successful people do
okay they they look out there and they
say this is where i want to be
we've already identified that then we
ask ourselves the question
what has to be true for that to occur
that's not true today okay and we've
already established
some a couple of those things one is
you're going to go back to school two is
somehow you're gonna have to prepare
a way to eat while you have to take a
little bit of time off to finish that
schooling
and we're going to get there and oh by
the way along the way we're going to get
out of debt
and along the way we're and oh man
they're going to pay for it for you so
this is getting even better
because there's tuition reimbursement
i'm loving this all along as a matter of
fact you might find a program that would
allow you to continue to work there and
do your
do your practicum there uh or whatever
it is you're having to do i don't know i
haven't finished yet you just started
this is going to be awesome
awesome hey cara can i just talk to you
every day to cheer me up
hey kara listen i'm gonna tell you this
in 30 seconds
okay my mom didn't go to college she
came from an ecosystem that didn't
invite
didn't support that at 42 she took her
first community college class
and then she took another one the next
year and another one the next year this
is my mom i watched it happen
and then at 53
she graduated no i'm sorry at 57 she
graduated with her phd
at 63 she was tenured and at 70 she just
stopped being the department chair at
the university that she now works at
so here's what i want you to that's a
map that dave's just telling you
honey you're just getting started you
have a whole
age
you're talking to a 60 year old and i'm
pissed off now and listen
dave's old trust me he's old but he's
still going
right just you're dead
when we get
you got the back half to go you've just
played nine holes and you've got nine
more to go it's
encore baby take a bath i'm just feeling
like exhausted
hey you should be you should just
finished a freaking battle
a 18-year battle
a 20-year battle and you got battle
fatigue yeah and i i
am proud of the fact that i don't like
i'm not frivolous i mean i have my times
where i spend here and there that i
shouldn't if you haven't done some
stupid stuff you wouldn't be human
exactly yeah stop but i don't vacation
things like that okay so here's what
we're gonna do here's what we're gonna
do
okay you need to go through financial
peace university because you get this
stupid credit card stuff and this
bankruptcy stuff in your rear view
mirror
instead of out your windshield i'm tired
of it being in your windshield it needs
to be in the past yeah and you put it
back there we're going to stop doing the
stupid stuff that puts you there
and that's the healing of your finances
are going to put you on track to go be a
pa
you're going to be a pa yes you are
and you're going to make more money from
55 to 70 than you did from 25 to 55.
and it's going to be so fun and
you're gonna you're gonna throw your
shoulders back and go look at me i did
that's right
so you have taken care of everyone else
and now it's time to take care of you
you've been proud of everybody else and
now it's time to be proud of you
ding ding girl what a stud man
you're amazing hold on kelly's going to
pick up we're going to put you in a
ramsay plus membership for a year
as our as our gift to you to put you on
the way
and uh we want you to get in there and
get into financial peace university get
the every dollar app going
and get your get your finances
straightened out go to kencoleman.com
start following the stuff ken is doing
on career and
uh you have 30 days to start taking
solid steps on this journey
i don't want to talk to you again 60
days from now and you have done nothing
except wine you should be 30 seconds
ten nine eight seven
six five four three
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 16 9
in their hearts human plan
humans plan their course but the lord
establishes their steps mark cuban said
work like there's someone working 24
hours a day to take it away from you
get them get them like that get them i
love it
jake is with us jake is in knoxville hi
jake welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave how are you doing great man how
can we help
oh i didn't know uh dr john was going to
be on the show with you today otherwise
i would have
revamped my question but the question i
called in about was i'm taking the uh
financial coach master trainer course
and
obviously everybody it doesn't follow
the dave ramsey playing the debt free
plan so how do i coach somebody
obviously with the goal in mind that i'm
going to try and make them or have them
come to the conclusion that the
debt-free lifestyle is is the best way
to do it but if
they're insistent upon credit score
and credit cards how do i coach them to
do the wrong thing in the best way i
guess
okay i don't really understand the
question you're saying that you
you're a financial you're gone through
our financial coach master training
and someone's gonna come in and pay you
for financial coaching
and they don't want to follow your
advice
not exactly just along more along the
line though
well that's that's exactly if you're
going to teach if your advice is
don't build a credit score and your
advice is don't use
debt but they're bound and determined to
do it how do you coach them the answer
is
you can't you fire your client you move
on
same thing in counseling if you're
making recommendations and you're
if you're a marriage counselor and the
husband is sleeping around on his wife
and you say dude you don't you've got to
stop that that doesn't work in marriage
and he says oh but that's what i believe
i believe it's okay and you go
i can't help you i'm not a good you're
an idiot yeah
i'm not a good fit for you yeah you're
gonna have to go find someone else that
has a different belief system
level but i get i get the reference um
so i would just
not coach somebody like that but then
that would take away from
possible income on my side no it won't
because if you coach people to do stupid
stuff
you're not going to get new clients
you want to teach someone to do the
wrong thing efficiently
yeah i think back to your question
brother
i guess yeah i guess that makes sense
yeah i mean because here's the thing
words gonna get out on you that
that you're coaching people to do the
wrong thing well
jake it sounds like you don't believe it
do you believe it no i absolutely
believe
in the debt-free lifestyle my wife and i
are on baby step two and we're getting
ready to
uh pay off our debt come october
um yeah i got a friend i got listen i
got a friend the other day that leased a
car okay he's a friend of mine
but he did a stupid butt thing he leased
a car okay but
he he you know and he can't come up to
me then
and go uh i'm not gonna go well here's
the best way to lease a car
i'm gonna say don't lease a car don't
lease a car so guess what he didn't ask
me because he knew what i was gonna say
not everybody initially comes into
coaching thinking oh i'm gonna get debt
free
obviously that's something we want to
lead them to on their own to make that
decision
based off of the information that we
give them but exactly but
in the meantime how do i in the meantime
you continue to say
this is what you need to do yeah don't
use that
i'm not going to teach you how to use
debt it's like someone calling me on the
radio
and saying how can i build my credit
score
i'm not going to assist them in doing
that although i know how
to assist them in doing that but i don't
believe it's good for them
and so i'm going to say i can't help you
with that what i can help you with
is that here's the reasoning why you
don't need to build your credit score
because it's an indication you've been
borrowing money your whole stupid life
it's not an indication that you're good
with money a high credit score is not an
indication that you're wealthy
it's not an indication that you're smart
it's not an indication of anything
except you paid a lot of
interest to some stupid but bank for the
last 15 years
this is the only way you get an 800
credit score and so i'm not going to
help you build your credit because i
don't think it's good
for you uh if you want to do that you're
going to do that on your own
and you know but here's the thing
if you're gonna if you want to be
agnostic as a
counselor you're gonna be an effective
agnostic to the principles think about a
basketball coach if you
don't care about winning you're not
gonna be a good coach right
and so if your player comes and says hey
i see that you want to run this offense
but really i just want to jack up three
pointers all day
then i'm not going to be your coach
you're not going to be on my team that's
the only way you can do that right yeah
you cannot be agnostic to principals
when you're coaching
especially for short-term business gain
that will fail in the end
every time every time
yeah when uh when people want to
buy agnostic i'm not talking about faith
i'm talking about you you're you're
not tied to the principle as having it
works
once you be i'm not agnostic to the
law of gravity right i believe it
[Laughter]
i believe it's a law i've experienced
its effects correct
and if my three-year-old grandchild
wants to
do something that's going to put him at
risk i'm not gonna go we'll try that
flying thing and see how it works all
right
just jump your butt off a two-story
building and see how that works out for
you
i'm gonna stop him from doing it because
i'm because i love him and it's going to
hurt him
you know it's a law it's a principle and
i'm not agnostic but
the three-year-old grandchild in their
ignorance may be agnostic
too they don't give a rip about the law
of gravity because they don't understand
its effects yet
and so this is you have to adhere to
principles in order to coach
and so when you're a financial coach
you've got to have your firm principles
this is the way
i teach how to be financially successful
and if it's not a fit for you that's
fine
because listen if you want to leverage
if you want to buy nothing down real
estate and you want to leverage
and go up your eyeballs in debt and buy
everything in sight
and not think anything about debt and
the risk associated with it and you
don't think debt is bad
you should see my good friend robert
kiyosaki he can help you with that
robert and i are friends he's a great
guy he and i completely disagree on this
and he's not agnostic about it either by
the way he's he
totally believes it's the best way to
build wealth and i firmly believe it's
not
and but we're still friends we don't
disrespect each other and
anything like that but you know if you
want to buy nothing down real estate you
don't need to call dave ramsey he's not
going to help you with it
you need to call robert he'll help you
with it and so i'm not a fit for
everyone
if you want to be a bitcoin billionaire
you don't need to call me
because i'm going to tell you bitcoin's
stupid don't do it and and
you know which i need to say that at
least once a day because it keeps the
internet really buzzing
i'm happy to say the more i say it the
better it goes so
the better the better the uh social
media people the bitcoin
coin warriors it's my favorite thing to
stir up since the gold bugs
when but anyway yeah i don't believe in
buying gold either there's some
let's piss those guys off i don't
believe in buying whole life life
insurance let's piss those guys off
i don't believe in buying a car on debt
ever
under i'd ride a bicycle wait a minute
do you like buying time shares dave
tell us i mean you know this is the
thing so you really really really
you got to make that call jake and uh
that's why john was questioning whether
you believe it or not i believe you do
believe it
but i think you're just trying to be a
nice guy
and help everyone and yeah that's a
great point you can't do that
you're not going to be a good fit for
everybody it's going to cost you some
business and you're going to need that
extra coaching client and you're not
going to get that money per hour that
you've got built in
because you stuck to your principles and
that's how you win
long term and they'll say that guy jake
me and him don't agree but he doesn't
know who he is
and he's honest he was honest with me he
was honest with me told me not to do it
and
i've uh this is who i'm gonna be this is
the plan i'm gonna follow i'd love to
take you there but if that's not for you
then so be it
yeah that that that's the thing it's a
good question it just takes me a minute
to unpack
why do i believe why do i think that
because it's automatic for me yeah
after all these years of doing this it's
just autopilot i don't even think about
it
well and and i'll tell you back in grad
school we had some class sessions
on how to appropriately
break up with a client say i'm not a
good fit for you and i'm sorry
but you know what there's a it is a
skill you gotta learn right
but there's this thing and it's not jake
but there's this thing in this culture
and jake we're partially reacting to
that that
we're supposed to be okay with everyone
and i'm not yeah because some of them
are dumb yeah
you know you just need to you need to do
it you know you need to go that's just
there's a right and there's a wrong yeah
there's a good and there's an evil
and it's you know there just is yeah and
this thing
you got to be willing to do that you got
to be willing to do that or you're going
to be ineffective
dr john deloney puts this hour of the
ramsey show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it
you